لا تهتز كييف بالقصف الروسي وحده ثمه في
اروقه الاداره الاوكرانيه تفاعل وصراع من
نوع مختلف الرئيس الاوكراني
راس الجمعه جلسه خاصه لمجلس الامن القومي
والدفاع وحسب تصريح له تركز الاجتماع على
نتائج التفتيش على المفوضين العسكريين او
مسؤوليه تجنيد في عموم البلاد
كشف زيلينسكي عن اكثر من 100 دعوه فساد
جنائيه ضد اولئك المسؤولين العسكريين
وتحدث عن عشرات منهم تحت مستوى الشبهات
وقرر الاطاحه بهم جميعا
نحن نطرد جميع المفوضين العسكريين يجب ان
يدير هذا النظام اناس يعرفون بالضبط ما هي
الحرب ولماذا يشكل التشكيك والرشوه في
اوقات الحرب خيانه محاربه الفساد مسار
يستعجل به زيلينسكي المزيد من مساعدات
حلفائه الغربيين وتلك عقده كانت بين
الطرفين في ايام الحرب وتبدو حاجه كييف
متزايده لمزيد من العتاد الغربي فتزامنا
مع اقالات زيلينسكي قال وزير خارجيته
ديمتري كوليبا ان الصواريخ بعيده المدى
حاسمه وضروريه لانتصار بلاده وطلب من
الشركاء توفيرها في اقرب وقت توضع هذه
المناشدات في سياق صعوبات يواجهها الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي روجت له كييف طويلا
قبل حلول الصيف ولا يبدو انه اثمر كثيرا
صحيح ان المسيرات تصبح داخل الروسيه بشكل
شبهي واحدثها ما تحدث عنه عمده موسكو يوم
الجمعه لكن القوات الروسيه تحرز تقدما في
بعض الجبهات كخار كيف التي بدات فيها
اوكرانيا مؤخرا عمليات اجلاء وتحديدا في
محيط كوبيا مسك ليس في خاركيف وحدها لكن
العقبات امام الهجوم المضاد مبثوثه على
طول خط التماس بين الجانبين المزروعي
بحقول الغام مت الطبقات تتفادى كييف عثرات
الهجوم المضاد باستنزاف الجيش الروسي
وخاصه طرق الامداد وبناءها التحتيه لعل
هذا ما يفسر ايضا تكرار استهداف جسري
القرم اللذين يعول عليهما كثيرا الجيش
الروسي في امداداته واذا الاستنزاف
الاوكراني استنزاف روسي مضاد يصوب نيرانه
نحو العتاد الغربي ويوسع نطاق شغل الطرف
الاوكراني بمواجهات ميدانيه تعوقه عن
تركيز طاقته في الهجوم المضاف